a calf and I were in the Amazon in 76
taking ayahuasca we got in with a
certain group of people in Peru that
took it every week and you know cultures
have different ways of handling hassle
and in some cultures its confrontational
and other cultures not the way these
Peruvian country folk operated was if
somebody was screwing up
nobody would ever say so they would just
talk about these people behind their
back until the Morpho genetic field of
gossip was so strong that you would
basically awaken to the problem so there
was a complex social situation going on
in this ayahuasca circle which was there
was a master shaman who we were
apprenticed to who was beloved by his
neighborhood but he had a nephew of
sobrino who was a jerk in this guy was
as Don Fidel said ambitious he dealt a
little weed he did a little pimping he
was just sort of an edger on any type of
guy and every Saturday night we would
all get together and take ayahuasca
about 30 of us older shamans are guy
people from the neighborhood and this
Sabrina Don Jose so I don't know what
the real history of it was because I
have just arrived on the scene but these
old guides would sing these echoes these
magical songs on ayahuasca that appear
as colored tapestries in front of your
eyes and you know they were they had
soul they were into it they were and
this guy would sing against them I mean
it's the rudest thing you can possibly
imagine and imagine if you know Lou Reed
we're trying to give a performance from
the guy in the third row just launched
into old man a river
and capped at it you know I mean in this
town I'm sure large guys would appear
and say sir info really didn't work like
that
they just kept singing he kept singing
and it was clear that this is how it was
going to be handled that we had just
divided into two separate entities here
well my wife was sitting next to me and
he was sitting across the room from us
the sobrino and I had been watching him
for a long time and I was loaded to the
gills and I could see he would get up on
his haunches and he looked like a monkey
he his face it was uncanny
I mean he looked like a monkey he also
looked kind of like a jackal a dog with
long teeth kept going through these
changes and and happening over to me and
said something like this guy's [ __ ] I
just said you know let it slide what do
we know think of it as anthropology she
she wasn't having it so after a while he
kept doing this and at one point and
everybody in the room every person in
the room was bummed out and they were
looking at their laughs all eye contact
was broken it's actually when I was a
kid I invented a word the word is fard
ow and it means the embarrassment you
feel when someone else [ __ ] up you know
and you happen to just be there but
somehow the aura of it is so strong the
entire room is just wash and fired out
and the old guys are singing and the guy
is singing so then at the end of a
particularly intense clash of these two
styles
my wife just looked across the room at
this guy and like put the planning on
him and I saw these red arrows leave her
eyes and like like dotted lines
and they move fairly slowly you know
more slowly than you could throw a ball
or something well when this line of red
arrows got to this guy he was knocked
off his feet he fell backwards with his
legs in the air and there was a big
noise and all the singing stopped and
everybody in the room looked up and
these three old shaman who were sitting
behind Don Fidel who I to that point had
not heard speak any language but Quechua
one turn to the other and he says in
Spanish oh the gringa sends the Cibola